jose barrios making his 15th
start of the season and for me it's all
about the command and command of that
fastball when he commands that fastball
he works ahead
he gets chases with that slider he's
used to change up
less this year than he has in the past
but he still has to be able to throw it
occasionally to
give those hitters a third pitch to
think about but if he can get strike one
and he can use that fastball early it
should be a good night
and hernandez in the box and here we go
breaking ball check swaying and a call
third strike not sure if the pitch
or the swing is what will send hernandez
back to the dugout barrios doesn't care
either way you're walking back to the
dugout on strike three but this one
whether he swung or not was in the zone
and
look like he committed to this one
here's ahmed rosario
two strikeouts to get his knight started
well that's what they call setting the
tone right here
attacking hitters going right at him and
then just have to respect that fastball
he's got enough fastball he's got enough
run on it to make the right handed
hitters
conscious of the inside part of the
plate and he's got good good break with
that curveball
eddie rosario sends a nod to his good
friend and former teammate
the fly ball into left center field
playable a rise playing deep comes into
the grass so call and catch
and that's the inning jose strikes out
two walks a man cleveland doesn't score
and leaves one
j.c mejia will be the indian starting
pitcher but mejia in his last start in
pittsburgh
didn't go well gave up five runs in that
first inning
and six overall although he was capable
of giving him five
innings and they liked that but put him
behind the eight ball early
couldn't get to any of his pitches
left-handers are having a field day off
of this year 371
right-handers are hitting 133 29th pitch
of the inning second and third two outs
a one-two count to max
and the dirt that gets away from the
catcher hedges
and the run scores a rise i think the
ball hit his helmet and larnick
perhaps it tony diaz's behest stayed put
at third base twins got a run on a wild
pitch
what a good aggressive read right here
by luisa rise this ball didn't get too
far it looked like it actually might
have clipped one plate umpire alan
porter as well but
see this is kind of what i was talking
about with you see a lot of times the
the pitching coach of the catcher go out
he box and then he threw that curveball
about
58 feet hit a rise in the head and he
was trying to
summon larnich home to follow him it's
almost like a rise was anticipating that
flip
trying to protect his helmet it got him
in the helmet no batting gloves
six home runs 20 knocked in the pitch a
swinging a missed strike three on a
spike curveball
rio strikes out his third one out naylor
can turn around about anybody's fastball
so what did burritos do
he went soft soft and softer and fed off
his aggressiveness got him to chase and
got a big out right there in the second
jose's 2-2 to zimmer on the way
strike three called in 95 came back in
and strikes out his fourth cleveland
batter talking about doesn't like the
ball
in on him a little bit and again he kind
of flinched thinking that ball's inside
but that's a great pitch for jose
two on two outs and now the number nine
catcher austin hedges and the one-two
pitch a broken bat flare into left field
shallower rise coming out that's going
to land for a hit
around third scoring is bobby bradley
that's a broken bat
single to left from austin hedges and
cleveland ties up the game one to one
jose upset himself right now he's
shaking his head out of the mound
he went back to the well he went away
with it and he's thinking my goodness oh
so close but he hung that one a little
bit well he's probably thinking man
i thought i had him struck out austin
hedges delivers
a 1-1 game cleveland baddie lengthy
second two on two out full count
two hernandez runners off she got him
strike three on a fastball
and that's the inning jose shouts into
his glove as cleveland runs up the pitch
count they do score one they strand a
pair so 1-1 your score
here's the 0-1 swung on that's poked
back to the mound third base side picked
up by mejia
throws low good scoop by naylor in time
for the out and naylor throwing it
around the infield
threw it to eddie rosario and left and
he throws it into the seats
now the one two to blanco called strike
three good pitch on the inside corner
and mejia looking for a quick inning
here you set down the first two
that's his fifth strikeout on the night
and up steps alex kiriloff
here's his pitch to kiriloff and he
chops one back to the mound
easy play for mejia who fields and flips
to naylor in time for the out
and just like that three up three down
just does have three home runs he's
walked into three and he's driven in now
eight on the year half swing strike
three
strikeout for barrios strikeout number
eight two down base is empty ahmed
rosario
line drive caught by donaldson at third
base hard hit 108 off the bat
of rosario three up three down nice job
there
one one game six thinning two down
kepler awaiting the payoff pitch from
mejia
here it comes straight three call
gets his sixth strikeout of the ball
game painted the outside corner and
what a job by j.c mejia tonight six
innings allowing one run former twin
eddie rosario
indians twins tied at one base is loaded
one out
eighth inning the pitch and it's swung
on ground ball base hit to center
that'll score hedges here comes ahmed
rosario
on his way to third jose ramirez and
eddie rosario
gets a little sweet revenge three to one
the indians take the lead andy rosario
now with 41 runs batted in
and that might be in his mind his
biggest hit of the season
well you figured he would come in here
and really want to try and do something
special for the indians against a team
that he loved playing for but they never
really made an offer to him and
i think he was hurt by that tom and this
is a great way
to try and get back at them three to one
indians runners at the corners
still only one out eighth inning runner
goes pitch swung on ground ball towards
second
polanco's only play is to get the runner
at first
that'll score ramirez eddie rosario by
running on that play stayed out of the
double play
bradley puts the ball in play gets his
13th rbi
and it's a 4-1 indians lead as they have
scored three here in the eighth inning
and with that dominant backside of the
indians bullpen
this is how the indians keep winning
games
even with the injuries to all of the
starting pitching
four to one indians twins batting ninth
inning runner at second two down
and here's alex kiriloff two and one the
count
he fires runner goes to third pitch
swing on bounce to first
chest high hop naylor flips to first
ball game
so the indians come to minneapolis and
win
game one in this weekend four
game series the final tonight cleveland
four
and minnesota won